people in Hollywood are still reeling
over the news I just mentioned Angelina
Jolie and Brad Pitt divorce not a lot of
details about the specific reason
Angelina filed for divorce but some yes
sir you and the audience
excuse me Conan I have a theory maybe
she got tired of chiseled handsome
leading man types and is looking for a
change okay yes sir I got hate to break
it to you it's not gonna be you okay
okay
look sir I am Telling You you do not
have a chance no we all have a chance
the only one who doesn't have a chance
anymore is Brad Pitt she's been with the
best let her try the rest right
[Applause]
Oh calm down buddy I mean Angelina isn't
gonna be interested in you if anything
what she needs right now is maybe a soft
cuddly type someone cute and
approachable and it's warm as a favorite
sweater
okay Andy you're married yeah but but in
Hollywood so what do you say Angelina
I'm no major movie star but I make a
mean omelet I'll Drive the kids to
school oh yeah I'm just seven payments
away from owning this Kia Sedona plenty
of room for us and your kids Angie come
on call me no wait
call me if you don't want to be with me
that way if I don't hear from you I know
that you want to be with okay sandy just
stop it Andy what's gotten into you I
don't know there's just something about
her just settle down
Angelina if you're watching I'd like to
apologize on behalf of my audience and
Andy it's just that you have a radio
that makes sensible men act foolishly
and I'm no exception I know it's hard to
imagine the two of us together so I took
the liberty of making a little photo
album here's us having coffee
[Music]
yeah
pretty good here's my two kids and your
kids playing in a pool together and if
things go right who knows maybe their
wedding bells down the road yeah plus
Angie I just made the last seven
payments on Andy's minivan it's mine now
you treacherous son of a [ __ ]
how about Angie this could be us
[Music]
[Applause]
I have the body of a horse
[Applause]
you